[تصفيق]
عليكم ان تفعلوا مثل هؤلاء لتثبتوا قدرتكم
على توفير الحياه الكريمه لزوجاتكم اما من
يرغبون بجلب الحظ السعيد والسكينه فعليهم
ان يمروا من اسفل هذا الهودج او حمله
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عادات وشعوب
مرحبا بكم في تايوان الالاف من السكان
حضروا الى مدينه ايلان للاحتفال بالعام
القمري الجديد هذه الاحتفالات تمتد ل 15
يوما في اجواء كرنفاليه يشارك فيها
المتزوجون او المقبلون على الزواج فهؤلاء
يقام لهم مسابقه خاصه لاثبات قدراتهم على
تحمل مصاحب الحياه الزوجيه وحمايه الزوجه
او اقناع الشاب لاهل خطيبته بانها في ايد
امينه فيحمل كل رجل زوجته او خطيبته على
كراز خشبيه تثبت على ظهورهم ثم يركضون بهن
لمسافات امام الجماهير التي حضرت للاحتفال
[موسيقى]
حمل الزوجات على ظهور الرجال ليست تقليد
الاحتفاليه الوحيده هنا فالطقس الرتب
والشوارع المبلله لم تمنع المشاركين من
لبس احذيه خشبيه صنعت خصيصا لهذا الاحتفاء
فالرجل وزوجته عليهما ارتداء حذاء واحد
والسير به للدلاله على المصير المشترك
ووحده الاسر والتالفها
[موسيقى]
لكن ماذا عن هذا الهودج وما السر وراءه
يقول السكان هنا ان الاله تمازو او الهه
البحر لدى التايوانيين تجلس داخل هذا
الهودج الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه ثلاثه امتار
ويحمله اكثر من عشرين شخصا يجوبون به
شوارع المدينه في مسيره موسيقيه فهؤلاء
يعتبرون مازو الراعيه لهذا الكرنفال
الشعبي لدرجه ان البعض يتسابقون لحملها
لاظهار تفانيهم وايمانهم ان لا محدود بها
واخرون مروا من تحت هودجها لاعتقادهم بان
ذلك يشفي من الامراض هو يجلب السعاده لهم
[موسيقى]
شاركونا ارائكم ما هي اغرب الطقوس التي
شاهدتموها والتي قيل انها تجلب الحظ
السعيد
[موسيقى]